six 178 3-0 47 50 let's go next to our
caller from the 207 area code caller
from 207 who's this where are you
calling from what's on your mind today
207 are you there
last chance 207 if you muted your phone
we can't hear you one more hello can you
hear me yeah we can hear you know okay
great
my name is Leland calling from the
Boston area I am calling about the video
you made about Alexandria
Acacio Cortes so I've got a little bit
of a problem with it honestly and just
full disclaimer I like the show I'm a
member and I followed you for a couple
of months now but I don't think you're
giving her enough credit for example I
think you know the the bigger issue is
you know when I see something pop up on
my youtube subscription feed that says
you know some it's some negative
basically video thumbnail title about
Ocasek Cortes I think you know well are
you are you giving her credit where
credit's ooh and I and I know that the
video you said that you agree with her
on most of the issues but I feel like
it's a little problematic first of all
when you don't make similar videos about
all the things she's doing right I mean
I'm sure you covered her when she was
when she was running and and you know
when she won the primary and and that's
important but you know the the little
nitpicks about her tweets and and
whether or not it's it's like exactly
the right strategy or or whatever I
think I think it's kind of harmful and
so first of all one of the things you
mentioned in that video was she
responded to dawn juniors trolling
basically she he posted a meme or
something and she responded to it
basically saying that he should be
careful because the house will have
subpoena power and and it will be a
Democratic House in January and you kind
of framed it as if that was as if as if
she was threatening to
ahem or-or-or investigate him over some
right-wing meme and that's really not
what she was doing I mean if you look at
the context basically what she's doing
is issues just sort of like flexing her
muscles and showing that that she has
the upper hand in this case than that
well but you're saying a lot and there's
so much here that we could break down so
what you're saying is she's not actually
threatening him with a subpoena she's
showing him that she has the strength to
subpoena him right I mean it seems like
you're saying he's not threatening over
as a meme I'm saying she's not
threatening the subpoena over what she
said with it with the right wing me do
you agree that it was widely interpreted
to be what I said it was yes in that
segment you at least concede that part
no I don't agree because I you know I
get a lot of my news online and I've
read a lot of the comments not usually
on duty because those are kind of cancer
but I read discussions and largely it
seems like all these you know all these
tweets of hers and and how much he
speaks out is actually having a really
positive impact and that people
appreciate that she's finally calling
out the people in power and doing so
without even being in office yet okay so
it sounds like you just haven't seen
that there have been numerous articles
including some from legal experts who
say this is a really bad idea because
even the appearance that she might be
saying she might use the house's
subpoena power in response to Donald
Trump Jr's treatment of her even the
appearance of that is problematic so it
sounds like you just didn't see that no
the article that I read about it as
specifically was from the hill I believe
and it seemed to have been her in a more
positive light and and didn't didn't
really put words in her mouth which I
think that's kind of what that's doing
okay I don't I guess we just disagree I
mean to go back to the bra it sounds
like we're not going it seems like you
didn't see a lot of the articles that
explained why this was a bad idea you
saw an article that liked it which is
fine but one article doesn't really tell
us much I guess I wondered and what I
participate in the discussions and I try
to see and see more perspectives but I'm
open to suggestions on where else to
look
that my perspective mr. Naro yeah I mean
I would just google it I don't have you
know I didn't know you were going to
call in with this question so I don't
share links handy
I guess the bigger question is you're
you said that in every every time I
issue a critique of her I should also I
guess be mentioning the positive things
she's doing or you didn't like the ratio
of negative to positive things that I
said in that clip is that I'm trying to
understand the criticism it's well it's
less about the clip because I saw that
you did you know specify that and that
you agree with her on a lot of things
within within that clip but the problem
I think is that you know when you think
she's slipping up a little bit and and
and some you know minutiae and within
tweets and stuff here and there I I saw
they even make a video of it but she's
been fighting for the green new deal and
she's been fighting for a lot of really
great progressive causes and I've spoken
so I guess here's what I'm asking you
when it the rubber hits the road
I've spoken positively about those
things in other clips in the clip where
I criticized her I even went out of my
way at the beginning middle and end of
the video to say that she has the right
ideas on many issues this is way more
than I do for almost anyone that I
criticize on the show what more did you
want me to do I think it would hello
hello hello can you hear me yeah you cut
out there sorry I must be problems I
thought so what I was gonna you're
cutting out again listen I'm gonna need
you to just email me what it is you want
me to do I
we just can't hear you but listen I I'm
treating her I'm almost treating her
with kid gloves if there's any criticism
is that it's that I'm going to out of my
way to couch my criticism in a positive
way which I barely ever do specifically
because I know people are going to say
that it was an unfair criticism so I I'm
not sure what else I can really do let's
take a quick break we will take more
calls after the break if you're holding
don't hang up we'll be right back